there was a large free Palestine rally
in Dearborn Michigan yesterday and uh a
couple of Clips well here's here's the
first clip before we get to the one the
funny one um some some familiar slogans
being chanted let's let's watch
this Palestine will be free pal louder
from the river to the sea from The River
To The Sea Palestine will be free will
no justice no no justice no no justice
no
justice free free
Palestine I want to hear that drunk free
free Palestine free free Palestine free
free Palestine free free Palestine they
said the American government said what
happened last Saturday was unprovoked we
don't want to be violent we are not
violent people we are full of
love but when you have 75 years of
ethnic cleansing 56 years of occupation
15 years of a blade that means nothing
is unprovoked in Palestine they have to
understand that's why we are frustrated
here
today okay so adopting of course the
slogans and mantras of black lives
matter and we know from experience uh
with BLM that no justice no peace is an
explicit endorsement of violence and
it's a pledge to continue violence
particularly against innocent people um
they're saying they don't want peace
until all their demands are met that's
that's what peace means is exactly what
I want that's the point of the chant but
we're just talking about leftist
disconnected from reality and there's no
better example than I think this next
clip from the same
speaker and here's what he
says so don't let them get it twisted
this is not complicated when you go to a
black lives matter rally you see
Palestinian Flags when you go to a white
supremacy rally you see Israeli Flags
this is not complicated when zionists
March down the street they say death to
Arabs when we March down the street we
say free free Palestine free free
Palestine this is not difficult
everybody okay now I'll admit first of
all I don't know exactly what white
supremacy rally he's talking about
precisely um I haven't seen any rally
that could even vaguely be described as
a white supremacist rally uh recently
but but if I'm if I did you know if I if
I did stumble across something that you
could actually call a white supremacist
rally whatever that would be I'm pretty
certain there wouldn't be any Israeli
Flags there in a world filled with
uncertainties you need to be prepared
for any possibility you need my Patriot
Supply my Patriot Supply is your trusted
partner for emergency preparedness
whether it's a natural disaster a sudden
emergency or unforeseen circumstances my
Patriot supplies highquality food
storage solutions ensure that you and
your loved ones are always wellfed no
matter what comes your way right now my
patri supplies are offering $25 off a
3-month food supply to help you stay
prepared for anything go to prepare
withth walsh.com and grab this special
price before it ends your three-month
emergency food supply provides over
2,000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations you can enjoy a wide variety
of my pay your supply and can even
customize your supply they offer an
ultimate breakfast kit a mega protein
kit with real meats and even a
glutenfree kit each meal is delicious
and has a shelf life of 25 years don't
wait for disasterous strike before
taking action invest in your safety and
well-being by securing your food storage
today go to prepare withth walsh.com and
save 25% off a three-month Supply that's
prepare withth walsh.com
yes yes you know that white supremacists
those famous fans of the Jews that's the
one thing that's the one thing that ties
all white supremacists together is how
much they love Jewish people if there's
anything that defines a white
supremacist it is his unbid uh love for
for for the Jews you know it's it's it's
a
great and the white supremacist that's
the thing I mean you hear from the white
supremacist all the time and they're
always going on and on and on about how
we need to protect Israel they just they
won't shut up about it it's it's it's
the most important thing to them is we
got to protect
Israel um I kind of wish I could hear
the rest of this guy's speech just to
hear what other super relatable
scenarios he
describes you know you know what I love
about going
to vegan rallies is they always give out
Outback Steakhouse coupons that's my
favorite thing about
them just no part of that makes any
sense at all until you realize of course
that um it doesn't appear to make sense
because if you're someone who lives in
reality and you're saying in reasonable
person and you hear that there are
Israeli flags at a white Su premises
rally you know that doesn't make any
sense to you but then you realize that
when when he talks about white
supremacist what he means is
just any white person who doesn't agree
with him is a white
supremacist um which is also the leftist
definition of the
term um or or maybe more broadly uh any
conservative so he's talking about any
any rally that's politically
conservative is white supremacist and
that's where you see the Israeli Flags
now even that isn't true you know I've
been to I've never been to to a white
supremacist rally uh I've been to plenty
of conservative ralles and
demonstrations I don't know if I've ever
seen somebody flying an Israeli flag at
a any demonstration I've been to in my
life but that is what he's referring to
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast